oh
c'est l'heure de votre journal de
l'afrique sur france24 bienvenue à tous
la confusion au mali pourquoi soldats
ivoiriens ont-ils été arrêté à
l'aéroport de bamako bamako et abidjan
se contredisent on tentera d'y voir plus
clair avec samuel bernard notre
correspondant à abidjan dès le début de
cette édition à la police sud africaine
sur les dans deux fusillades en un
week-end de bach pris pour cible l'un à
soweto l'hôte à pietermaritzburg
19 personnes ont été tuées
aof de soulagement au sénégal plusieurs
convois de camions de marchandises ont
pu reprendre la direction du mali après
six mois d'embargo contre bamako
depuis leur arrivée à l'aéroport de
bamako les spéculations vont bon train
49 soldats ivoiriens ont été retenus par
des gendarmes maliens il n'avait pas
d'ordre de mission selon les autorités
aéroportuaires et toute la journée
plusieurs versions tt avancées se
contredisant la dernière information en
date le gouvernement malien qui parle de
mercenaires samuel bernard aa bonsoir
vous êtes notre correspondant en côte
d'ivoire que s'est il passé
alors ce qu'on ce qui est ce qui est
très impressionnant pour les jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on voit vraiment on
peut contrôler les deux versions des
autorités ivoiriennes et celle des
gouvernements de transition somalien en
compte véritablement deux histoires donc
il est très difficile de savoir ce qui
s'est passé donc deux histoires autour
de ses 49 soldats ivoiriens qui ont
intérêt donc à l'aéroport de hyères soir
alors selon les autorités ivoiriennes
avec qui
nous avons discuté aujourd'hui ses 49
soldats ivoiriens cet intérêt à bamako
le petit juillan passé en fait ils ont
passé la nuit donc au camp un vrai
gendarmerie de bamako pour des
vérifications voilà ce qui était dit car
les autorités maliennes donc avait
considéré qu'il n'avait pas d'ordre de
weeds de mission les autorisant à
rentrer au mali mais selon l'armée
ivoirienne est également donc selon le
porte parole de la minus masse soldats
avaient bel et bien un ordre de mission
vous autorisant à entrer sur le
territoire et maliennes avaient été
prévenus donc voilà alors côté malien
donc c'est une toute autre histoire
sanitaire
donc se trouvait ivoiriens se trouvaient
selon elle on sortir un communiqué il ya
quelques il ya très peu de temps donc
ces unités à royan se trouvaient
illégalement selon eux sur le territoire
malien il s'agit de mercenaires dont la
profession réel donc a été dissimulé des
soldats qui serait désormais entre les
mains de la justice alors voilà ce qu'on
peut dire pour le moment il faut rester
très prudent et très difficile en fait
d'avoir une vision claire de la
situation et surtout donc du sort de ces
fameux ce tas pour rappeler que cet
épisode se déroule un petit peu plus
d'une semaine après la levée des
sanctions économiques et financières
la cdo entre le mali et la promesse de
la junte malienne d'accélérer l'agenda
électoral avec une élection
présidentielle prévue pour février 2024
merci beaucoup à samuel bernard le
correspondant de france 24 en côte
d'ivoire l émotion à soweto le plus
grand township de johannesburg les
habitants ont été nombreux à se masser
sur les lieux de la fusillade de ce
week-end 15 tués 9 blessés près 240
coups de fusil tirés dans un bar est la
police est à la recherche des cinq
tueurs présumés une autre attaque a fait
quatre morts câline le bellec
[Applaudissements]
un simple bar devenu une scène de guerre
à soweto la police traque sein comme
responsable de la fusillade samedi soir
ils ont tiré au hasard dans la foule
avec des armes de gros calibres des tirs
à plus de cent reprises ils ont tué plus
d'une dizaine de clients et ont blessé
plusieurs autres
daphné possible au second plan quand je
suis arrivé à la taverne j'ai trouvé des
corps allongés les uns sur les autres et
le sang coulait toujours de leur cadavre
je n'ai pas vu la voiture qui aurait
fait cela j'ai cherché parmi les corps
les membres de ma famille ma tension est
montée en flèche
au labour de nouveau la route hubert
le week-end dernier a été
particulièrement sanglant deux autres
bars dans le pays ont aussi été victimes
de fusillades quatre personnes ont été
tuées dans un bar à pietermaritzburg et
deux personnes ont été abattues à 4 les
angles le bilan des morts durant les
quatre premiers mois de l'année est le
plus élevé en cinq ans avec une moyenne
de 67 personnes assassinées chaque jour
mais même sans cette hausse l'afrique du
sud avait déjà le taux le plus élevé de
meurtres sur tout le continent les
autorités s'inquiètent du nombre de bars
et de la forte consommation d'alcool
dans le pays qui selon eux engendré ces
violences les riverains de soweto
voudrait plutôt des solutions au taux de
chômage chez les jeunes qui à plus de
60%
laurine gigant fruits sains farc pointe
du doigt les lois trop laxiste
concernant l' usage des armes à feu
dans une société normale la violence de
ce week-end aurait été élevée au rang d'
urgence nationale et les autorités
auraient mise en oeuvre des mesures pour
enrayer la folie au plus ce week-end
meurtrier est un choc pour un pays qui
reste bouleversé il y a deux semaines 21
jeunes ont trouvé la mort dans des
circonstances mystérieuses dans un bar à
east london
il dirige déjà l'heure on a depuis 22
ans et se dit prêt à rempiler pour vingt
ans de plus paul kagame n'exclut pas
d'être candidat à sa succession et ce
dès 2024 date de la prochaine
présidentielle
le président a fait ces déclarations à
notre chaîne c'était vendredi dernier et
depuis l'annnonce fait grincer les dents
c'est au président
interrogé sur une éventuelle candidature
pour les prochaines élections
présidentielles de 2024 le président
rwandais paul kagame a déclaré
j'envisage de me présenter pour vingt
ans de plus je n'ai aucun problème avec
ça ajoutant que les élections sont
l'occasion pour la population de faire
son choix lors du forum de doha en 2010
neuf il avait pourtant déclaré qu'il ne
se représenterait probablement pas en
pour l'opposition ce revirement est
inquiétant je pense qu'il était temps
pour le président kagame de passer le
témoin est organisée une carte des nas
ordonnée lorsqu'il paraît des citoyens
rwandais qui ont choisi pour oui il faut
qu'ils ajoutent ces sont des citoyens
rwandais déjà terrorisée ce sont des
citoyens qui sont pendant 28 ans sous le
goût du parti ep assad à cette
configuration est ce qu'on peut parler
qu elle aussi très loin des emplois non
parce qu'ils ne sont pas libres de
choisir en 2015 paul kagame à porter une
réforme de la constitution adoptée par
référendum lui permettant de rester au
pouvoir jusqu'en 2034 cet article
constitutionnel continue de limiter le
nombre de mandats présidentiels à deux
tout en faisant passer sa durée de sept
à cinq ans cette révision
constitutionnelle avait fait l'objet de
critiques virulentes des partenaires
internationaux du rwanda notamment des
états unis le corps de josé eduardo dos
santos a finalement était au psi et en
espagne c'était une demande de l'une de
ses filles elles doutent de la mort
naturelle de l'ancien président
congolais décédé vendredi à barcelone
c'est là qu'il vivait depuis à 2019 pour
raisons de santé là qu'il avait été
hospitalisé le 23 juin dernier après un
arrêt cardiaque elle a porté plainte sa
fille début juillet pour tentative
d'homicide dans sa ligne de mire
l'épousé le médecin de son père et les
juges responsables de la dégradation de
l'état de santé de l'ancien chef d'état
il n'y a pas eu foule dimanche dans les
bureaux doigts du congo brazzaville des
élections locales et législatives
plusieurs partis d'opposition avaient
appelé au boycott du scrutin des
opposants convaincu que l'information
pouvoir conserverait toute façon sa main
mise sur le parlement le chef de l'état
denis sassou n'guesso a dénoncé cette
attitude les premiers résultats sont
attendus dans la semaine un second tour
est prévu pas de date annoncée
appel au boycott aussi en tunisie à deux
semaines du référendum constitutionnel
le fond du salut national demande une
nouvelle fois aux électeurs de ne pas se
rendre aux urnes cette coalition de
formations politiques rejette le texte
proposé par le chef de l'état kai eide
et ce malgré les modifications qu'il a
fait selon elle le projet de réformer et
taillé sur mesure pour celui qui s'est
arrogé les pleins pouvoirs il ya
maintenant un an une en tueur totale
avec le système parlementaire jusqu'ici
en place
si aujourd'hui on instaure un résident
de confusion des pouvoirs comme c'est le
cas dans le projet de constitution le
président a accaparé la plénitude des
pouvoirs dont les garanties la garantie
des libertés disparaît et donc il ya une
menace quitte rome sur les libertés
c'est pour moi la quintessence d'une
mauvaise pour ses tissus non plus c'est
une constitution qui a été rédigé par un
seul
liberté retrouvée depuis une semaine
pour les transporteurs sénégalais le
trafic de marchandises vers le mali
voisin a pu reprendre ils étaient
interrompues depuis six mois compte tenu
des sanctions de la cedeao et de la
fermeture la frontière entre les deux
pays maintenant que l'embargo élevé les
chauffeurs routiers veulent être
indemnisés par la communauté ouest
africaine à dakar la correspondance des
länder ouf de soulagement chez les
camionneurs qui assure le transit entre
dakar et bamako leur activité a été
fortement impactés par la fermeture de
la frontière entre le sénégal et le mali
seuls les denrées de première nécessité
comme le sucre le riz ou les
hydrocarbures étaient autorisés à passer
la frontière à les camionneurs qui
transportait ainsi des produits non
essentiels ont été fortement touchés à
part cet embargo à certains d'entre eux
ont même passé plusieurs mois à la
frontière entre les deux pays ah si la
décision de la levée de l'embargo et
s'allier à part ces transporteurs de
marchandises il me réclame tout de même
réparation du préjudice subi après près
de six mois sans activité pour certains
d'entre eux écoutez de plusieurs les
enfants ont démarré mais il ya des
tableaux qui sont en panne il ya les
marchés tous ceux qui sont gâtés donc ça
nous demandons réparation à part du
sénégal par le biais du moc salle qui
est membre de la zone euro pour qu'il
qui soit un autre avocat au niveau de la
stéréo pour les réparations puisque la
la ça monsieur n'était pas programmée si
elle était programmée à part ce moment
et que nous photos ratées bus et du tram
quand on nous la fournit revient là vous
ne rêvez pas mais que nous avons changé
qu'ils n'ont pas la possibilité de voir
contribuer au mali les acteurs
économiques de leur côté espèrent une
réelle reprise des échanges commerciaux
entre dakar et bamako le mali est le
premier partenaire commercial du sénégal
23 % des exportations à sénégalaises
sont destinés à son voisin mallié selon
lagence nationale sénégalaise de la
statistique et de la démographie des
chiffres qui ont été évalués avant
l'entrée en vigueur de l'embargo
le journal de l'afrique c'est aussi sur
deux réseaux sociaux et notre site
internet france 24 points comme merci de
votre fidélité à france24 reste avec
nous
[Musique]